the native landscapes of Sumatra are
disappearing with alarming speed every
year farmers here slash and burn large
swaths of rainforest mainly to make way
for palm oil plantations
they're also burning peat lands a type
of wetland that stores huge amounts of
natural carbon when peat soil burns it
releases carbon dioxide and causes toxic
smoke that's thicker and more dangerous
than smoke from other forest fires okay
once we had a volunteer firefighter who
got treated with oxygen because of
respiratory problems when he came back
after two weeks we observed that his
condition had become much worse
alongside the grave health risks they
pose peat fires have a devastating
impact on our climate scientists found
that peat fires in Indonesia pumped
hundreds of millions of tons of
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
this year peat fires are also
notoriously difficult to put out because
they continue to smolder underground
we cannot extinguish peat fires
completely especially in the dry season
we can only stop them from spreading
ritika testimony cemented gasbag Abu
Mohammed said war was moonkin major
the majority of peat fires are thought
to be deliberately lit others are the
result of bad farming in addition to
slash and burn practices farmers are
also draining peat land to grow palm oil
trees rendering the soil dry and
flammable for years palm oil cultivation
has been the go-to means to make a
living for farmers in Sumatra but some
are starting to make the switch this 58
year old farmer got rid of his palm oil
trees to grow chili a crop which doesn't
degrade the land chillies grow very fast
in the soil because it's mainly organic
matter
his son supports the switch to
alternative crops but says farmers
cannot rescue peatlands alone kana
inamura sabudana hmong notice that peat
lands have to be restored so they don't
burn so easily it's completely wasteful
to burn down people in a convenient
needle on Nova in 2016
Indonesia's government established an
agency to restore some 2 million
hectares of peat land by 2020 but
critics say much more it's needed to put
an end to the fires that are destroying
the country's precious ecosystems and
are polluting our planet
mark pellington is a senior scientist at
the Copernicus atmosphere monitoring
service that's part of the European
Union's atmosphere observation program
mark joins me now on the program mark
welcome
what is the environmental impact of this
amount of carbon dioxide being released
into the atmosphere I think the fires in
Indonesia in particular it's there is a
lot of carbon that's being emitted into
the atmosphere what the overall impacts
will be for the environments and in
terms of climate is difficult to
estimate at this stage the data that we
provide is really related to sort of the
direct emissions at the moment to really
understand how much of that carbon then
stays in in the atmosphere would require
like quite detailed modelling of the
carbon cycle and that's not something
that can be done in the near real-time
and will be something that will be
estimated after the fire season and
after the whole you know after the
vegetation response to the fires has
been taken into account as well so just
in layman's terms more than 700 megatons
of carbon has been released into the
environment should we be worried about
this or not it's difficult to say how
much of that will stay in the in the
environment some of it will be up taken
again by regrowing vegetation during the
wet season are doing the growing season
and so it's really difficult to estimate
how much so that then stays in the
atmosphere the the using co2 as an
emission from fires is quite convenient
way of trying to get across the the
level of the activity and the intensity
and it's also worth remembering that
there's a lot of other things that are
emitted as well as carbon gaseous or
particulate matter and other pollutants
which affect a local air quality and so
this is kind of two things going on is
the climate impact but then also there's
the direct air quality impacts that
direct that that's quite could be quite
hazardous to health of the people that
live in those in the places where
there's a
- fires taking place mark is there a
specific reason whether Indonesian fires
emitted more carbon dioxide than the
Amazon fires it's somewhat difficult to
compare directly between the Amazon and
what happens in Indonesia and this is
because there's different types of fuel
different types of vegetation that's
burning one of the critical issues for
Indonesia is that it's peat lands that
have become dried out that are ruining
and they burn in a very different way to
vegetation so smolders at low
temperatures releases a lot of different
types of gases and it can burn for a
long period of time so you could also
burn underground for example and then
resurface when the conditions change
mark pellington thank you very much for
speaking to us you're welcome thank you